another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr wright is  strictly prohibited from posting  classified information on 4chan in fact  he should know by now that he's not  allowed to go on 4chan using foundation  computers but he's definitely not  allowed to release classified  information on the forum this includes  but is not limited to pictures of  containment cells and various anomalies  such as pictures of scp-682 with the  caption mondays am i right you are not  right this is not permitted this also  includes information about any anomalies  contained on site as well as any  foundation personnel if dr gears is  microwaving fish in the break room then  that complaint needs to be handled  through official channels rather than an  unregulated internet forum